I've always been obsessed with finding
out whether or not video game mechanics
work in the real world like when I tried
to climb a wall like nathan drake i when
i tried to play mario kart in the real
world the problem is my DS they're
always too big so i decided to aim
smaller i wanted to know what it was
like to play pray while suspended in
zero-g
[Music]
can pray you're able to navigate outside
of the Tallis one space station in real
life I'm unlikely to navigate outside my
apartment but this seems like too good
of an opportunity to pass up Bethesda
had set me a challenge I had to breach
the airlock of Tallis one and find a
keycard on a human corpse floating in
the vacuum of space all while being
buffeted with gale force winds to
suspend me in midair for those out there
who have never been indoor skydiving
before it is way harder than it looks
any tiny movement of your body changes
your direction even just spreading your
fingers makes you zoom around the tube
or in my case run into the glass wall
like the Internet's favorite manatee but
after two training sessions it was time
for me to be kidded out for my attempt I
had a reinforced Xbox one controller
velcroed and duct taped to my wrist my
earplugs were in and I was ready to go
[Music]
I don't know which was harder orienting
myself in-game so I could find my
objective marker or orienting myself in
the real world so I could get off that
god damn glass wall after around 3
minutes though I'd managed to figure
both that completely through Blind Luck
and I set off in search of that human
corpse what I ended up finding was a
nuclear reactor that I promptly crashed
into and died I started to reload for
another attempt unfortunately pray was
yet to be patched so the load times were
pretty long while I waited for it to
load I started to become very aware of
the velocity of wind that was shooting
up my nostrils the only way I can
describe it was it felt like someone
jamb two water hoses turned to full
pressure right up my nose we also found
out that shooting someone from behind
while they're suspended in midair is not
the most flattering angle after a little
while I tapped out unsuccessful but at
least I still had my pride then this guy
got in
well that was incredibly difficult as
you saw it was very very windy in there
and the load times were exceptionally
long but you can stay tuned again spot
for most different stuff that I'll no
doubt do in the future and I reckon that
would be way easier with a switch so I'm
going to try that next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]